*dab*  *dab*  *dab* and more dab
It's ass time everybody Merry Christmas (did the devil came?)
It's time for me to play your levels
Super Mario Bros world 1:1
*laughs*
Someone remade Super Mario an ass legend how do I even can I even do that god damn it?
Whoa maybe I need a car  oh (oh wow..)
Let's do the helicop-
the butt propeller of course
Oh my god
good vehicle
Come on. Can you be a little more shit?
There we go, butt propeller. Yes.
Oh god oh god
Oh god go up go up go up
god dam-
This is how Super Mario was intended
We finally realized how to play it properly
You are welcome
why buy Super Mario
when you can buy ass and get su- the better
version for free everybody
Here we go, just like Shigeru Miyamoto intended just like you want. That's a oh God
Show me Super Mario.
I meant the real Super Mario. Oh god.
No.
what? Oh secret secret oh oh I went down the pipe, haha
Oh my god, I'm so bad at this
Oh, are you kidding me?!
alright eject
They're weak, and I'm back everybody
huh
Is there gonna be oh there's a flag
Hey hey
That's so creative
Well done the Godfather. That's awesome.
You guys are so talented. I am so proud.
What is this? the deep mines
Okay
These levels with no vehicles seem very popular
You can't enter the mines yet you forgot your pickaxe
What is this, minecraft?
What the hell that doesn't even look like a pickaxe?
Okay fine fine. I'm grabbing the pickaxe
You collected the pickaxe
Incredible
I totally have the pickaxe right now. You may now enter the cave.
Thank you game. Oh, No-
Okay, all right. Be careful, be caref-
Hey look at that checkpoint everybody
I'm in the cave playing Minecraft, this is great
geh
So cute, kawaii desu ne
Really into this techno music. It's really good
I did it with my pickaxe everybody?
Gets to get a like. I don't spit shit, but you know unfair level sure buddy
Hey, it's another one with the vehicle. Why did we even add vehicles in the game?
What the hell I?
Gotta go back here. Oh my god. Okay, what else you got oh?
oh
Oh, no damn it come on
There you go sucking ass, thank you
Unfair level more like annoying level
Okay, alright. What kill me last time. Oh my god. Well fuck this level
Okay, I challenge you version eight no problem
Look at that
Easy
No, no go back. Yeah, physics really makes sense in this game. Don't worry about it
This is just how Isaac Newton wanted it damn it. This is too tiny bit old to get in
Come on dude fuck that this is too hard
I can't I can't Harry Potter chicken parkour 100% legit Wow that sounds fantastic
Oh look. It's Harry Potter
Everybody just as I remember now. You can jump in midair?
Oh yeah someone modded I don't know how you did this. That's pretty cool, too bad. I still can't get up there
Come on
Come on Harry Potter
There we go Jesus okay, well, this is totally not possible. Yeah, no problem. Oh
OH!
Jump oh
Harry potter man
thats awesome Harry
Wow
Why do I suck at jumping so much there it is
There it is I'm so good at games
aww!
How
Okay, I can't beat it, but it was really cool that you did that
Angry Birds great, they're all levels without the cards oh
Wait I get the car, okay
Now never mind jump to shoot
Whoa what oh my god
Target one banana
oh! what?!
That is so creative oh my god
That is so cool
Target two blue crystal, okay? Whoa? I don't think I did it
How am I supposed to hit that
Great I am so impressed. That's so creative
oh
Damn it!
There it is yes perfect
red crystal no problem
oh! wow!
wow
Hey
Wait what target for shoot yourself to the goal okay, okay here I go
hahaha no!
Okay here we go ah
Ah!
Dared Oh wham and virus well done, that's so cool as amazing
Don't mind the curse, okay. I won't cuz clearly no one wants them. Oh my job
Okay, I won't mind the cards don't worry
My god
oh shoot!
Don't explode
Eh she-go's cars, please stop stop it
Thank you
Virus at it again you fucking weirdo, what is this swim fast? I'll have you know I'm an excellent swimmer
Okay, you know what right the beach. I don't need the car anywhere
There we go so excited. Oh, I got the car again great
What it what is happening I don't
oh
But we're in a kook we're in minecraft again. Everybody don't worry about it. No
No
I'm fine, okay, we're swimming
Right we're swimming. Okay. I did it okay. Why do I have to swim fast again?
Okay there we go
Uh-oh all right, I'll go this way oh my god
Go go go go go go
Twenty foot pootie pie
go
Swim goddamn it. You're so slow, dude
That motherfuckers just chilling there
dammit! Oh
I'm fine. I'm fine everybody. I'm fine in fact. I'm doing excellent. Thank you for asking
ow
Great are you kidding me?
There it is there it is look at the speed boy look at this speed boy
we are going eighty eight miles an hour boy!
OOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHH!
I did it!
wow ho ho ho ho
He was the best pilot!
He's the best pilot in the galaxy
wow he actually did it everybody, my god look at ah!
come on man!
Oh
meh no ho ho
I did it. Yeah. Ya-ta so...
What is happening now where I go back?
No no oh, I just have to keep going, I just don't know where I am
No don't go back
Don't go back
Never look back on your mistakes, and oh god not again. It's gonna come again. No I did it oh
Wow I'm free I'm safe Willy oh oh
Wow
So far so good. Oh my god, go faster
No no no no no no no, I don't need this in my life
Thank you very much PewDiePie test
Number one how old is PewDiePie
Yes, oh let's see here. Oh look at that. I'm 28 by the way not 27 and two old foot
All you think you're smarter than me
Okay, alright. I'm seven sure I'm seven haha
What the hell was the right answer then?
Wow what a great quiz oh my god, it was a trick question I fell for my own quest
Look, it's 20 none of these are oh my god
Incredible
With what words did plead my first video start
What the fuck is that?
Yeah, oh my god. I think what the f is that
correct
Who is Peter Pan's wife say Yuri Yuri, or not Sookie easy Yuri best girl oh
Oh it glitched out like that's oh
Of course it's Monica. Yes only Monica. Oh, that's awesome
Oh, no. Oh, oh I made an oopsie oh
The game is breaking. It's just Monica
Hey, hey Monica. Hey day Monica. Hey Monica Hey
So fun
St guard well done amazing job to all the people making levels. I'm so proud of it
It's so fun obviously. I'm so proud of everyone making the game as well double moose
Check out the game support it. I would really appreciate it and
Hopefully we can release
very soon on all consoles
Thank you very much for watching this video keep on making levels and as always
squad Fame am